and so Lisa what's the latest well at
the start of all of this
Harry Dunn's family were told that there
was going to be a 1% chance of getting
justice they were told that by at
someone in British Authority and now
they will be feeling that the odds have
improved somewhat I understand that at
the moment the family are being
officially told that AMSA coulis has
been charged with causing Harry Dunn's
death by dangerous driving now I was
with the family yesterday when they were
told that that was going to happen we
set out so long ago that we believe that
we believed we believed and we've done
it we've done it we we've got the charge
this is it we I'm just it's amazing
absolutely amazing it's amazing justice
whatever happens now it doesn't matter
we've got we've got what we wanted here
means everything I would never bring
rested properly
at the start of all this Harry's family
were thinking it was going to be a
clear-cut case and then they found out
that am Saku laughs had claimed
diplomatic immunity and gone back to
America and in those many weeks since
they have been fighting for justice on
November the first police handed the
Crown Prosecution Service their file and
the Crown Prosecution Service had been
thinking about charges since then now
the family know that this case is going
to progress they're under no illusions
though that extradition proceedings are
about to get under way so they're going
to have a long lengthy fight ahead of
them and that this really is the first
good news they've had really and since
they lost Harry Dunne or I Lisa thanks
for that now we've just received a
written ministerial statement from the
Foreign Office which I can read you now
it says I told the house on the 21st of
October that following the tragic case
of Harry Dunne I had commissioned a
review of the immunity arrangements of
the kraut an annex for US personnel and
their families who hold privileges and
immunities under the Vienna Convention
on diplomatic relations following the
27th of August Road collision in which
Harry Dunne was killed I committed to
completing that review by the end of the
year the cratan review has now concluded
it considered the anomaly that family
members of u.s. officers serving at the
annex at RAF crowdin have and the
current arrangements between the UK in
the United States greater protection
from UK criminal jurisdiction than the
officers themselves on the basis of the
review I have instructed my officials to
begin discussions with the United States
on the most effective way to address
this anomaly that's from the Foreign
Office